so you're at home you're looking for
something to read got a suggestion for
you today it's a chilling new novel
describes a flu-like pandemic similar to
the corona virus outbreak that we're all
going through the name of the book is
called the end of October it's about a
virus it starts in Asia Indonesia in
this case and very quickly spreads
across the world Pulitzer prize-winning
author Lawrence Wright started writing
this book listen to this at the end of
2017 and he finished it just last summer
whoa Lawrence Wright good morning to you
I can't wait to meet you in person
because let me tell me say this about
your book it is terrifying and it is a
page-turner and I want the audience to
get an idea about what you have to show
the similarities as we said the deadly
virus starts in Indonesia goes global
there are supply shortages check there
are not enough testing check there are
stay-at-home orders check the
vice-president is charged is in charge
of the response check check so this is a
question I know your friends are calling
you a prophet what drew you to this
story what did you see what do you know
Lawrence right well I was interested as
a young reporter I did some stories out
of the Centers for Disease Control in
Atlanta and that's when I first got
enchanted by the ingenuity and courage
of people who work in public health and
so I you know years later Ridley Scott
asked me to write a screenplay about
something that causes civilization to
collapse he never made the movie but it
brought me back to the idea that a
pandemic such as the 1918 flu if it
wreaked returned and in our society how
would we babe would be better prepared
than our ancestors wore that was a
question that I was putting to the
experts I talked to well this is a thing
because Larry you're not a doctor you're
not a scientist because when I was
reading I thought he must have some kind
of medical background what you are is a
very very good stellar reporter but can
you talk a little bit about your
research because I read at one point you
even talked to your dentist yeah well I
Gayle I like to work for
facts you know from real life and it's
more interesting to me to find out what
really happened or what would happen and
so in the case of my dentist I had not a
dental operation in the in the novel and
I interviewed him about how it would be
done you know they were he's you always
discover things by talking to people who
really know the answers and so I feel
more comfortable writing knowing that
that's how it really go down yeah I mean
that's how it really went down and it's
it was so eerie I have to say reading
the book because so much of what you
wrote in the book is happening now so
when you when you first heard about
kovat 19 number one when did you hear
about it and what did you think when you
first heard it well it was New Year's
Eve when the Chinese made that
declaration that there was this new
virus and you know often times new
viruses especially flu viruses arise in
Asia especially in China and it was
already you know at a dangerous level in
China we didn't know how dangerous at
that point but I was alert to that and
by oh you know towards the end of
January I was already stocking up on
groceries and I'm ordering masks and
gloves because I just thought the
viruses don't pay any attention to
borders and this one's gonna fly across
our border it sure is is anything and
and it wasn't very long before it did
get here let's talk about dr. Henry
Parsons because people haven't read the
book what can you what do you want the
audience to know about him because of
course I'm thinking Anthony found she
but that's not these just briefly tell
us about him well actually Gail Henry
Parsons that may I borrowed the name
from a little-known epidemiologist in
the 19th century who is the man who
demonstrated that influenza was caused
by contagion and not by environmental
gases my asthma's and you know he's been
pretty much forgotten even by
epidemiologists but I tipped my hat
he is a man who has been touched by
disease himself he represents the world
that I set this novel and the world of
medical science and these intellectual
adventurers who the epidemiologist who
charge in two places where novel
diseases arise and they have no idea
what they're dealing with but their
mission is to find out and to stop the
spread and that's that's the world that
Henry comes from yeah the difference in
the book as humanity is showing itself
here in what we're going to there's a
loss lack of loss of humanity in the end
of October I won't give it away but boy
Laurence Bravo Bravo
very well done thank you thank you very
much the end of October got it was my
pleasure the end of October goes on sale
next Tuesday wherever you like to buy
your book